let's talk about suppression of
information we have the story from CNBC
this website's struggling to stay open
Twitter reportedly limits employee
access to content moderation tools as
midterm electioneers the move comes
before the midterms Elon Musk said on
Friday he will be take after taking
control of Twitter that he plans to form
a Content moderation Council so this is
this is potentially big news whether
it's intentional or not so here's what
we have
according to yoel Roth I think his name
is this is normal for a company
transition after a sale the reason being
you got a bunch of disgruntled employees
they're about to be fired you lock
everybody out you keep only trusted
people to have access otherwise someone
goes what's up who cares cnbc's trash so
uh we know the story's happening the
issue is they're concerned about company
transition regardless of that this means
that right now Twitter is effectively a
free-for-all
it doesn't mean you can do whatever you
want because they are Banning people
Viva fry got suspended for like no real
reason but it just goes to show you the
machine's broken right now so people are
probably going to build are going to be
able to post a lot of stuff though we
are seeing probably it may be worse
because now it's hyper automated so
you're going to be getting a lot of
weird stuff but but Biden himself got
fact checked that was really interesting
nice amen right before a week before the
midterms heck of a time for this to
happen what do you think happens well
Dave Smith starts trending this is
processing yeah he's trending right now
oh what's he trending for oh no that's
being awesome what did Biden say that
got fact checked he talked about the
inflation reduction act
um uh being an act that's going to allow
the mega corporations to be taxed and he
was fact checked being like well only
some of them might be taxed under this
new law maybe uh but he was saying we're
going to get more revenue for all these
huge companies in the billions of
dollars and then you know the fact check
was well so you got like a little tag on
underneath his post or what yeah I think
uh oh he's got a couple of them it's
it's not just this one he said some
seniors pay 400 bucks a month for
insulin it's ridiculous thanks to the
inflation reduction act we're capping
that cost us 35 bucks a month and that
says readers added context while the
inflation production act capped
inflation at 35 bucks for individuals on
Medicare it did not cap costs for
seniors on private insurance
out of the 8.4 million Americans take
insulin only 3.3 are covered by Medicare
and there's a bunch of these he's
getting fact checked a lot there was one
about taxing big corporations here you
go look at this one
let me give you the facts let me give
you the facts Jack in 2020 55 operations
made 40 billion and they paid zero in
federal taxes my inflation reduction
reduction act puts an end to this and
then you get the fact check the
inflation reduction act imposes a
minimum tax on corporations with average
pre-tex earnings greater than a billion
out of the 55 corporations he references
only 14 head earnings greater than a
billion so he's full of it I don't know
I don't know maybe taking away Twitter
moderation tools from most the staff
just means that we're now going to see
Democrats and journalists on the left
actually start getting flagged it's
going to be interesting because
Bloomberg is reporting that only some of
the employees lost their access to
content moderation and policy
enforcement which ones uh what was this
about we don't know yet we don't know
the details here but there have been a
lot of people after Elon Musk that that
you know acquired Twitter that have been
censored like view afraid that you
mentioned that did get their accounts
back so I I think I suspect personally
he got his account back because he
complied with the BS takedown oh did he
wow yeah they said delete your Tweet you
can come back so we I'm pretty sure he
did and then said Fu because Elon Musk
also is sending out messages to people
like don't worry we'll help you soon he
sent a message to Michaela Peterson when
she reached out to him saying it's only
going to be in a matter of time we'll
fix the problems uh is the problem being
fixed now with some of these people
being taken away for for censoring
people for their political speech I
think that is possibly What's Happening
Here uh but only time will tell it's
going to be interesting to see how this
moves forward especially with the
pressure from the federal government and
the DHS that of course wants to censor
speech that wants to limit the
conversations that people could have
naturally between themselves in a
Draconian totalitarian way you know
what's going to happen here is going to
be interesting you ready for the real
good news deadline says Hollywood's
Twitter Exodus who has quit who has
threatened to quit and he who refuses to
leave so uh there's a bunch of these
stories they're mentioning wrestling
Legend Mick Foley wrote I'll be giving
some serious thought to leaving blah
blah blah but he hasn't left I think
that's the biggest name there NBC news
also had a very similar article and I
didn't know who they were talking about
I was like who are these people they
showed pictures of four people I had no
clue and no idea who these people were
oh
what's his name man mankind mankind yeah
a range of other prominent figures have
either threatened to quit Stephen King
signed off for a break which may or may
not be permanent Tony Braxton Teo Leone
Josh gadd Brian koppelman Alex Winter
and some expressed concerns Kara Swisher
or have definedly said they will stay in
fight Rob Reiner and George 10K the
funny thing is Eli on doesn't get it
Elon he doesn't get it commies don't
want to pay for things okay that's just
it so he can he can he can charge
whatever he wants to do once charge
they don't they don't even want to pay
for for they don't even they don't do
work they want free school they want
free everything and that just means you
pay for it they want to be on Twitter
they want to have verification they want
you to tell everyone how important they
are and they don't want to pay for it so
here's my advice to Elon let them go let
them Drift Away Into Obscurity we're
having a conversation over here on
Twitter that's where that's why George
Decay said I'm not leaving because he
gets it that's why I said Donald Trump
has no choice but to come back if they
reinstate them it's where the
conversation is
remember Will Wheaton when's the last
anyone's heard from him
you don't want to be active on these
platforms by by all means go ahead and
leave and then you know good luck I'm
not saying it's the end of the world for
these people I'm sure he's doing
something he's got a YouTube or
something going on and there have been
people on the right who have been banned
they still very much exist for sure Alex
Jones is doing his thing
but what if you if you willfully want to
remove yourself from the public
conversation go ahead and do it
I almost did that last year actually I
went through this little thing because
of all the censorship it was like well
screw this I'm out of here and I decided
to stick with it and just be more loud
and more obnoxious and sort of wait for
them to just kick me out but uh I think
the thing is these people are running
from one from hearing another Viewpoint
you have one side of the aisle that's
like
I'm going to stay here and be loud and
and say what I want to say
shooting for truth Fighting For Freedom
uh but then you have other people that
don't want to hear it and that's why
they're leaving you know they're sort of
afraid that it's under the guise of hate
and uh intolerance and they don't want
to hear it so they're going to run but
then there's also this Eight dollar per
month uh inconvenience that but it's not
the final nail in the coffin so hey
would you rather a company be dependent
on the whims of multinational
corporations complying with the ESG
score or would you rather a company be
independently funded and not need to of
course bend over to of course the
globalists and the internationalists and
the corporations to me eight dollars a
month I'll gladly pay for it if Elon
Musk keeps his promise to protect free
speech and allow people to have their
political voices disseminated without
any uh you know destruction of those
voices without any kind of censorship so
so I'm willing I'm gladly willing to
have her Twitter blue for like four
dollars a month and that's basically
just gives you what it allows you to
upload it allows you to upload videos
that are a lot longer and it gives you
some analytics as a data that's four
bucks a month so Sarah barela says welp
it's been fun I'm out see you on other
platforms peep sorry this one's just not
for me George alexopoula said who are
you
that's hilarious hey look she's got 2.8
million followers yeah I have no idea
who she is
exactly Harmony I still have no idea I
have no clue but but what's Happening
Here I I'll bet your bottom dollar right
now that that all these corporate media
companies are reaching out to all these
celebrities and saying hey are you
hearing Mick Foley might quit are you
going to be brave and quit too can we
sign up your name too to this article
hey can can you can you stand up against
this bigotry and this hatred are you
going to do the right thing and and say
you're going to get off Twitter once the
hatred comes back in there of course
calling all these celebrities and trying
to bait them into pushing uh this larger
attack against Twitter and that's
exactly what's happening I want to tell
you who's Sarah Bareilles is she is a
Twitter user with 2.8 million followers
who can barely muster a couple dozen
retweets or likes on any of her content
yeah I mean all of her tweets no
engagement so see this is the
opportunity for a lot of these has beens
they have a lot of followers because
they gained a lot of followers for doing
something but now they're not relevant
anymore how do you make yourself
relevant standard to finally and say I
have almost three million followers and
I'm leaving well nobody nobody look look
this is my point though see how she gets
like no retweets anywhere 31 wow 31 30
19 but hold on when she says I'm leaving
six thousand with 40 000 replies 75 000
likes it's just PR that's all it is it's
it's it's a it's a it's a yeah but the
bigger question is how many of those
followers are real she's not getting any
engagement did she buy any followers is
there no no no no no no what happens is
someone like Sara Bareilles she has that
big song I'm not going to write you a
love song or whatever she has other
songs sure people listen she probably
gets a ton of traffic on Spotify but
that song was really big when that comes
out she's in the Press everywhere tons
of people then follow her but for no
reason no one's following her to listen
to her opine on her politics
so when it comes to actual engagement
they don't they don't engage for people
like us
that people follow us and we follow
others for the conversation not her so
she can't get any engagement a ton of
followers it's useless for her so what
does she do now is a chance to to get in
the news what happens she's in she's in
the store she's in deadline
congratulations you made the Press
a platform that you had no engagement on
that no one cared to listen to you and
you could use that to boost your your
your status it's the same thing with um
I saw another article and it had a list
of like celebrities on that level where
it was like oh I know them from that one
thing like Alex Winter from Bill and Ted
was leaving and he's in the list now so
it's like everybody got the memo and
everybody made their statement and
they're like I can't do it I'm out and
so then now you're seeing Alex Winter
who oh oh yeah that guy Sarah barrielle
who's that oh yeah that song yeah yeah
yeah I should check that song out that
was a good song Toni Braxton she tweeted
I'm shocked and appalled at some of the
Free Speech I've seen on this platform
since its acquisition hate speech under
the veil of free speech is unacceptable
therefore I am choosing to stay off
Twitter as it is no longer a safe space
for myself my sons and other POC Heavens
please Tony keep your children indoors
at all times heaven forbid they go
outside and hear a naughty word of a
random person walking down the street
the first response here is hilarious by
Ron Coleman right there
the GIF of people laughing in their face
do you know how much terrible stuff is
on Twitter that apparently they were
never ever really worried about prior to
you all right thank you there's porn
there's hardcore porn on Twitter right
now and you're like well now it's not a
safe space right there's radical
jihadism there's people getting their
heads chopped off there's crime there's
like Gore some brutal videos all on the
platform of course no problem there's no
there's no problems with with that yeah
but this is too much we got to write
down the lucasms of course I'm gonna
create my own language here but but
anyway like you go on there
keep going uh you go on there and then
this is the issue people people just and
it hasn't even really started yet we're
not seeing a big change to the platform
yeah yeah nothing happened and these
people are freaking out that they're
leaving okay this is why
you know Elon is gonna learn the hard
way that
he he mentioned this a while back that
he hopes to create a balance it's not
about making any one side happy it's
about making everybody you know
compromise he doesn't get it we are the
compromise we are the ones who are
outright saying these people advocate
for violence they are psychotic they dox
people and we are willing to say okay
fine let them have their awful opinions
and do their thing we'll mind our own
business they say no either ban them or
we walk that's what Will Wheaton did he
said if you don't ban Alex Jones I'll
quit and then they didn't then equip and
then they eventually banned him anyway
Elon
there is no compromise with with these
obstinate Psychopaths acting like all of
a sudden now the platform is dangerous
for her sons she has no problem with
like the murder videos that are on
Twitter there's war footage of people
being blown up I have seen videos of
people writhing on the ground with blood
spraying out of their body on this
platform I have seen videos of jets
dropping bombs I have seen videos of
white phosphorus and she's all of it
it's fake good luck Elon man can we talk
about this don't say we didn't work I'm
reading it and I'm thinking it's Toni
Braxton really sitting around reading
other people's tweets at home and and
what is in her news feed that is making
all this hate speech pop up because we
all sort of see what we are given to see
based on our own activity
you know I'm imagining her son comes in
it's like you know a month ago mom yeah
what is it I just watched a video of a
radical jihadist if you had somebody
yeah it's nice that's nice yeah then he
comes in a week later he's like Mom Mom
I'm watching two adults engage in uh
yeah yeah whatever that's nice then
she's sitting there reading the news
like Elon Musk buys Twitter no no no no
no this is not safe for my sons yeah
yeah spare me dude it's it's all of them
though yeah Sara Bareilles doesn't care
about this stuff they're just at some
point Elon you gotta recognize tell them
to go away go away get get out of here
if I go outside right now if I go
downtown to like any big city you're
going to see some of the craziest stuff
people be holding up pictures of dead
babies they're gonna be holding up
pictures of all sorts of nonsense
they're going to be screaming all sorts
of nonsense there's people who walk
around naked at Pride events they're
people there's there are performers in
Times Square who who get really close to
being naked you go to Hollywood you
might see some nudity all over the place
you're definitely going to see violence
hey if you literally go to New York City
you might get pushed onto the tracks
better keep your kids indoors lock the
room don't let them out because if
that's the reality you're scared of some
mean words that haven't even appeared on
the platform yet well okay then then you
shouldn't be going outside at all don't
make me have to pay for your fear nobody
in their right mind should be letting
their kids on Twitter without their
oversight oh no don't let your kids on
Twitter just don't give you you take
away their step one don't let your kid
up on Twitter
it's a Fray man it is The Fray it is it
is culture War Battle Zone yeah
I mean maybe take them on Twitter with
you to show them how crazy it is but
well Twitter needs to have like a safe
mode and not safe mode and that solves a
lot of the problems like that's what
mines does right yeah yeah so for work
stuff yeah you can have a safe mode
which is kind of like you know there's
some new stuff on it that's probably not
appropriate for kids but it's not really
that crazy and then there's the not safe
for work stuff which is war combat
serious crimes politics in my opinion a
lot of politics I don't know though I
think kids are allowed to listen to
politics and to a certain resp to a
certain degree I think most politics
probably fine most politics used to be
like this tax policy or you know things
like that I used to say religion wasn't
safe for work any kind of religious
stuff and then I'd get like Christmas
posts and I'd be like
all right by my own rules this is not
safe for work and it'd be like Holly
Jolly jingle and I'm like it's too
religious it's Christian are you yeah it
just stuck to my morals and I kept all
not safe for work if it's religious not
safe for work because not everyone's
Christian but it is safe for work but
it's not it's not something I want to to
appear on someone's computer in a work
environment because I don't want to
create divisiveness but why what's the
purpose of it like any kind of religion
this is their world view bro yeah our
world view is kind of like oh hey a post
about uh um you know Judaism
whatever I'll read it I'm interested in
seeing what they have to say I'm not
Jewish oh hey look Kwanzaa what's that
all about I'll read about that what do
you think Mormonism you know South Park
did a great episode on Mormonism where
they're kind of like ragging on the
Mormon faith and at the end of the
episode the Mormon family is just like
you know what we've been really nice to
you you guys are just dicks like the
Mormon family was really nice and
wholesome and didn't hurt anybody but
they believed things that the other kids
thought were stupid
um that's how I see it you post
something on on social media and I think
it's dumb whatever man if I disagree
with you I disagree with you that's the
conversation if it's like someone saying
if if I see like a a post about BLM or
something and it's it's it's in the uh
it's in the context of hey look at this
young man who was killed by police in
this story it's really sad I'm not gonna
be like screw you you morons I'm gonna
be like whatever you know yeah we
shouldn't be trying into appease
deranged children who never grew up like
these individuals put them in a safe
space put a play put play foam in there
here pad the walls up and make it a
virtual safe space where people could go
and they will prioritize feelings over
facts and then have a real place where
adults could go that could have serious
conversations Ed could handle the
realities of this world and not need to
be safeguarded from the truth so so this
is what Elon Musk has been talking about
doing he also has been talking about
sharing advertisement revenue and
revenue from Twitter giving it to some
of the content creators he's planning to
officially lay off 25 percent of the
company so this is going to be a very
big transition that we're going to be
seeing here and I think he's going to at
the end of the day offer people the
opportunity hey have your little safe
space you know be able just to see
Disney cartoons and and commercials for
big Pharma being regurgitated to you
could have that space he could make and
then you could have a real world space
they could make Twitter invite only
nodes
he could say that someone like uh you
know Sara Bareilles can choose electric
node which will give anyone who follows
her an invite to join the node and the
note is only her followers no one can
see anything inside of it or share
anything outside of it unless they're
invited to the node how about that have
you seen the tribal social yeah yeah
yeah like why aren't why aren't they all
flocking on over there there's a lot of
them are you know but here's the issue
The Daily Beast wrote that tribal social
is full of hate speech they're going
after tribal the same as they go after
parlor why because face CIA book and
Twitter you know actively cool with
government and the real advantage to the
centralized networks is the manipulation
of public opinion getting everybody to
go to tribal social is just as bad as if
it's parlor you lose control of the
narrative thanks for checking out this
segment from the timcast IRL podcast but
if you want to check out the full show
live tune in Monday through Friday at 8
pm and if you want more special show
access content head over to timcast.com
and become a member your membership
helps sustain this company keep our
journalists employed makes this show
happen and you will get access to
exclusive members only segments of the
timcast IRL podcast and there's a
massive library to check out so again go
to timcast.com or tune in Monday through
Friday at 8pm and we'll see you all
there